the Fond invasion the Onslow of bynars
coming onto YouTube this is kind of just
this substance list highly edited
garbage smell way to kill the vine the
vine just keeps growing
[Music]
so when vine shut down there was kind of
this exodus of its top talent that
basically hopped on over to YouTube and
have since become very successful I mean
you have the more controversial creators
like your Paul Brothers Lele pons two
very popular creators like david dobrik
or liza kochi and all these people kind
of built a large chunk of their audience
off of mine it's also very to me because
I somehow missed the entire vine craze I
don't know what I was doing I mean even
some of my friends were prominent
providers themselves including my buddy
Jack here the camera guy hey what up
squad I know I didn't like that kissing
to you aria I know man
I'm just kidding kissing my girlfriend
what was fine it's an app where it's
just six second videos you make whatever
you want and it just loops over and over
the downfall of vine was kind of
inevitable because it was just so
limiting to the people making vine so
you had a big following on vine so let's
let's break down your history on that I
had a viral video of my cat attacking me
and that was kind of when my vine blew
up I gained like twenty five thousand
followers in one day do you want to
build this nope
why didn't she make a full-on jump onto
YouTube like some of these other binders
I was just like lazy and I didn't keep
up with consistency and I think that's
what hurt me but I'm okay with it
I'd watch your videos man hey there's
some up there and you're not subscribed
so well what makes this whole topic of
Viners on youtube even more interesting
to me is the idea of a vine invasion
we've lost the war against the varner
invasion and they're definitely here to
stay I don't know if anyone else is
interested but I find it very
fascinating just because you kind of see
now YouTube has been around long enough
that we have
Fronteras you think of all the old
phases back in the day you know your
smosh's your KevJumba now we're in this
phase where so many of the top craters
are these former miners and some of them
not all of them but some of them have
come under critique and criticism for
their content these former miners don't
have a bad reputation because the
Internet is just full of haters it's
because their content is terrible
look I'm making these hilarious
repetitive content with sexual
references that is generally unfunny
please accept me so right now we're
gonna hop on a call with Leon lush he's
a youtuber based out on the East Coast
his content critiques and looks at
YouTube and internet culture through a
kind of a comedic lens he will be an
interesting additional perspective all
right does he own Lush Cosmetics hey
Leon what is it about vine content that
kind of you think separates it I will
say the majority of people I think that
came over from buying are fantastic I
would say kotico is probably my favorite
right now you have your Danny Gonzales
Drew Gooden crushing it right now
they've been able to leave the
six-second format and come over and do a
longer form style of content which is
what does well on YouTube but there's
always gonna there's always gonna be
comedy or styles of content that I and a
lot of other people think is stupid but
still has a large audience I truly
cannot fathom why this has 4.8 million
views I think this is like the vine
invasion we're talking about where it's
just it's this different kind of comedy
that I feel like people that are kind of
down to earth and I guess a little more
genuine they watch it they're just like
this is this is really really dumb wow I
feel like I lost 10 years of my life
just now watching that terrible comedy I
feel like there comes a point when you
watch these videos where your brain just
automatically dies the main kind of
culprits of this there's a company
called shot studios you're Lele pons
you're Hanna stockings today we'll be
looking at the worst studios has to
offer so all of it I understand there's
a market for it because that whole crew
came over from vine in is crushing it on
YouTube
because they do highly produce things
but it's just it's like these highly
produced turds
she tells him to get out the clues II
think it's about time to get out of the
closet huh what I'm always looking for
the punchline you can sort of tell that
they like God on set with a vague idea
of what they were going to film but they
weren't entirely sure it's just like a
bunch of like uncoordinated things put
together you hear a bunch of these ho
I'm ready you're familiar with that
sound yeah yeah there's about a hundred
airs about a hundred and forty of those
sound effects it's always like really
attractive people exploiting how hot
they are for a couple of seconds and
that's pretty much the punchline but
when you strip it away there's really
nothing left it's kind of just this
substance list highly edited garbage it
seems like so cold like nothing I've
ever watched from like any of these
people it makes you feel like you're
getting to see just like a little
glimpse into who they actually are as a
person I think what's so great what so
many people love about YouTube is more
than vine offered like it gives you that
connection with a creator it gives you a
chance to feel like you're getting to
know them a little bit and you're
getting to see who they really are
and I think the people that have done so
well in the transition have done that
aside from talking about these either
the ones we like in the ones we don't
there's probably a ton of Viners that
tried to be youtubers and just didn't do
so well I've seen that happen with a lot
of different people this guy was on
vinyl that's what I'm saying nice nice
jawline got the hair off that's a good
that's fine money right there baby
pretty lights on the tree to offer an
alternate perspective we head across
town to meet with Brittany Furlan who
was one of my most successful stars but
who never actually made the full jump
onto YouTube Brittany Furlan what do you
know about her she was one of the like
og Feiner she was on the app pretty
early but I think she was for a while
the most followed female Feiner did you
enjoy her content i the vines I liked
were different from her vines your
Soloff I was literally you screaming
yeah no I didn't like my vines either
[Music]
[Applause]
Jack nice to meet you too all the top
performers when I started were like
traditional comedians like Adam Goldberg
Will Sasso Chris D'Elia Steve Agee they
were indeed comedians you know and
people were like oh this app school and
like indie and I was like oh cool like I
fit in and then like batch and Logan and
Lela and Jake Paul and and all these
like young kids got on and just kind of
flipped like the demographic completion
oh yeah like I was doing prank stuff and
like hurting myself and stuff like that
and then Lele came along and then she
started doing like 10 times more than I
was doing like really hurting herself by
jumping off bridges I was like all right
I give up you can be number one like I
was like I'm not going that far I don't
know what happened it just got really
young and then I'd have like 7 year olds
telling me to kill myself and I was like
whoa dude because even reading those
words like for me just cuz I already
have such bad anxiety and depression I'm
like I don't want to be around this so
eventually I just stopped if I would
have just like bit the bullet and been
like I'm just gonna go to youtube you
know like Liza all those people I would
probably be way more successful but I
just couldn't like inside of me for
something about it I just couldn't like
force myself to do something that wasn't
really true to who I am do you feel like
they may feel the same way but they
still did it
yeah I think some of them probably do
yeah I think a lot of them do I mean I'm
not saying they're not like deep people
you know I think a lot of them probably
are like oh gosh this is so lame but
also like love the money and love the
attention and love the lifestyle it
provides you know because they're like
all loaded now you know they're loaded
there is kind of a defined by an
invasion style of con oh yeah like the
Viners took over what are your thoughts
on that content in general I mean I
don't watch any of it most of the people
who watch YouTube regularly I'm gonna
say are like below 20 do you believe
that I kind of is what's allowing these
people these vine tubers are still of
course because it's like they're like
like still laughing at the same stuff
like that like a kid would laugh at like
someone falling and getting hurt or like
Oh like when you run into your your
crush in public with your friend but you
look like crap
oh no you know like oh boy oh you know
and they make it funny and it's like
really big it's almost like vaudevillian
like they're all just like you know the
expressions are so big and everything's
so intense and like I think like younger
people really were like really react to
that if they didn't have their following
from vine if they were to start making
icon it today do you think they would
still have that same no I think you
Paige if there was no vine and they
didn't have somewhere to like launch off
of now throughout the day Jack had been
reaching out to his vine friends to see
if any of them would speak with me and
on our way back he finally gets a
response David said he could FaceTime
you FaceTime you like now yeah just pull
over so I know david dobrik my name but
just break it down who is he he had a
lot of success on vine and he has even
more success on YouTube isn't had like
tons of controversy not a lot of people
hate his videos he's like just a poster
child for transitioning from vine to
YouTube oh hello not yet okay okay hey
Dave again my name is aria thanks for
doing this you having a good day we we
met in we both lived in Illinois when we
were on vine
hey you're welcome dude so I kind of
wanted to do a deep dive into how vine
has transitioned over onto YouTube and
so I just wanted to sort of get just
your perspective on kind of how that
transition was for you I didn't make the
transition because vine was dying and I
think that's why it worked it's because
I literally made it just because I
wanted to try it but a Viners took from
vine what everybody learned from it is
that like people like to watch things
there are quick and fast paced so when I
transition I took a how to present it up
the whole fast-paced stuff and just
applied it to my videos you mentioned
how you took the vine elements and
you've kind of you've adapted well
enough whereas there are other creators
that have tried doing it some other
thing where they take the vine elements
and just kind of make long-form versions
of it - not quite as positive a
reception there are people that make
stuff just to make money maybe they
don't love creating videos my cup of tea
or it's not your audience but there are
younger kids that are enjoying it and
there are other people that are enjoying
it you know other than tension is all
genuine or not I can't really complain
if other people are enjoying it then I
shouldn't be upset about it what people
do to build their audience and entertain
people you know it's all love man I I
understand it you know it's fun to make
fun of these people but they're they're
just doing them and there's a market for
that style of comedy so so I say more
power to you I think Viners will
continue to thrive
I really do I don't see them going
anywhere I just see them getting bigger
and bigger and infiltrating movies and
TV and everything they're gonna be the
ones that are putting shows on different
platforms they're gonna be hiring
YouTube talent to do more jobs I think
YouTube is gonna be a bigger a bigger
thing in a couple years I think it's
here to stay
there's no way and I killed
the vine just keeps growing they're very
sweet Hey look at our holiday sweaters
figured out holiday sweaters man I
appreciate david dobrik taking the time
to speak with me although i entirely
blame him for my car battery dying
during that call and now here we are
stuck in the middle of it who left the
car on idle there's no need to point
fingers Jack I think it's not so much
Viners or youtubers but just
personalities now at this point and it's
going to be really Justin to see just
how YouTube and the internet and media
as a whole continues to evolve over a
nine teams of course of the next two
years but even like in the coming months
because that's the thing about the
Internet it's a fickle Beast and I keep
talking because I'm hoping that Triple A
will finally answer but unlikely
[Music]
you can own weight under the mistletoe
where do you go
my favorite Christmas song baby
there's it matter if no buddy sings
alone chest